This video is brought to you by
Squarespace websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the all in one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business.
Had to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to go for lunch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain.
Okay,
now is likely you've already heard of
coco Chanel either from her famous perfume
or the luxury clothing brands based on
our name as a woman trying to build a
business in a time where the
world was controlled by men.
Chanel started at less than zero.
Then you had,
she found a way to climb to the position
of being one of the most wealthy and
powerful women in the world
on today is biographics.
We're here to tell you the true
rags to riches story of Coco Chanel.
Gabrielle Chanel was born on August
the 19th 1883 and Francis La Valley.
Her mother, usually Sean Deval
was an unwed laundry woman.
She gave birth to Gabrielle in a charity
hospital run by nuns on the day she was
born. Her mother had to ride traveling
where the father's name should be.
That wasn't just an excuse for an absentee
dad though because Albert's Chanel
traveled from towns down selling
clothes to local peasants.
Gabrielle has one oldest sister, Julia,
and they were less than a year apart.
The couple had their hands full with two
infant daughters and they could hardly
scraped by with what little money they
hat in 1884 Elvis and Joel's family gave
them money so that they could
pay for a marriage license.
Off to that union was official.
They had several more children and the
family all lived in a cramped one room
apartments in the town of Breve.
Like our day, Gabrielle Learns Outer,
so at an early age to help her
father with his clothing business,
but when she was just 12 years old,
Gabrielle's mother came sick and died.
Raising young children is
very much a full time job.
He could not earn an income and
take care of them at the same time.
He sent his sons to work on a farm and
the girls were sent to a convent to be
raised by nuns. The nuns
taught her discipline as well
is how to read and write.
She lands a carry herself with the grace
and the elegance of a lady rather than
a peasant. Most of the other children
living in the convent, they were orphans,
but since her father was still alive,
Gabrielle refuse to consider
herself an orphan too.
She held onto the hope that her father
would return one day and that they could
be a family again.
At this time in our life,
books acted as a way for her to get lost.
In a world of fantasy.
She began to create elaborate stories
about her own life as well to help ease
the pain of her reality laser in life.
One of the most common stories she told
her friends was how she was raised by
Hystrix aunties.
She continued to tell lies and
half truths about our past,
which made it almost
impossible for anyone to know.
Just how difficult her
childhood Trudy had been.
That's Age 18 Gabrielle,
the convent to find a job.
There are very few opportunities
for women to find work,
but she was lucky to have sewing skills
that should have learned from our father.
She won't as a seamstress during the day,
making clothing for the rich
ladies in the town of Milan.
This was a very solitary job
ans she was his in a backroom,
working long hours,
mending and assembling garments at night.
She worked a second job as a nice club
where she would sing and dance in front
of a crowd.
When she was 23 I actually caught the
attention of a man named Etienne Belle's
song. He was the ad, so the
wealthy Bellstone gamant company,
which supplied the French
army with its uniforms.
Gabrielle Chanel's started going
by the nickname coco. Yes. Later,
or even Chanel herself would
tell a different story of
where the name came from.
Somebody that was based on the
lyrics of a song she used to sing.
Others think it's short
for the French Coco,
which means a kept woman or in
today's slang, a sugar baby.
For someone in Gabrielle
Chanel's situation.
These wealthy men were the only
hope she had of escaping poverty.
Balsam had a type which was
aspiring actresses, the girlfriends.
He lived with him before Chanel
was named Emily Oh, dialing codes.
She went on to become rich and famous
with a successful career in Paris.
Gabrielle has no delusions about the
relationship that she had with and
[inaudible] and she knew that by sleeping
with him he could introduce her to the
right people. This
officer, a few auditions,
it was clear that she just wasn't cut
out for Shay business. She was staying.
It's Bell Saul's house in the country.
The Chateau de Roy low for a few days
don't was sets in the middle of the forest
where but also enjoy
riding horses and hunting.
When his guests came over the weekend,
he kept like his dirty little secrets
telling her it's 101 of the back bedrooms.
This was infuriating for Chanel.
It was clear that about someone
was willing to sleep with her,
but he was ashamed to be
seen with our in public.
Plenty of people would feel completely
dejected by this whole situation,
but instead of feeling defeated,
this sparked a fire in her.
She wanted to prove that she
was worthy of being this party.
The only problem was that the clothes,
she arrived in majors and now
they're on vias that she was Paul.
So she took one of ball
salts suits and cut it apart,
tailoring it to fit her body perfectly.
Then she showed up to
the party on invited.
She heard herself with confidence while
everyone's heads turned to to see this
beautiful woman standing
in a mountain suit.
When the guests asked why
she was dressed like that,
she casually said that it was
far more comfortable. Remember,
this happened in the year 1906 so
this was completely unheard of.
Women wearing corsets, long gloves, and
multiple layers of Scott's at this party.
Chanel was clever and it's interesting to
talk to you. When she made new friends,
she would make up elaborate
stories about her past,
just like she had done as a young bill.
She wants to add my life,
didn't please me.
So I created my life.
Basile was impressed by this stuff,
so he allows her to continue
living at his chateau [inaudible].
She joined is in a secular friends.
He began to treat her to
new clothes and jewelry,
but she continued to use
the fabric from Belle songs,
discarded clothing to make
herself outfits to wear instead.
For most women nodding,
there's a fabric feathers and Jules was
a way to show off that they were married
to someone who had a lot of money,
thought these things were rather vulgar
and she doesn't care if a simple style
may to look poor. She just wanted
to be comfortable. Soon enough,
other women began to copy cocoa style.
Looking at photos of Chanel and our youth,
it's almost as if they were taken today
or like if she was a time traveler sent
back a hundred years. He has an
idea. She was quoted as saying,
in order to be irreplaceable, one must
be different during World War One,
when everywhere began to wet pants because
they had to work while their husbands
were away,
but by the time the men married,
they wanted their wives to
go back to wearing dresses.
Of course women in the Aba class never
got to work a tool so they never stopped
wearing their core sets and the
layers of uncomfortable fabric.
If Coco Chanel was going to convince them
to change, it would happen in stages.
And over a very long period of time
when she was 26 years old,
Gabrielle mess,
an English businessmen named
off a capitalist, one of
FTO and bell souls potties,
everyone calls him by because he was
the illegitimate son of an aristocrat.
He worked his way up in the world to
become a self made man out of everyone in
Belle songs in a cycle.
He was one of the only people
who actually worked for a living.
Chenelle was not satisfied to sit around
and do nothing all day like other kept
women.
She was earning an income from selling
custom made hats to women who had moto
style. This, she got the money in cash at
the time, women could not own businesses,
rented apartment, so even have
bank accounts without a guarantor,
which was usually the
father or the husbands.
All the capital would see that Gabrielle
Chanel was a genius and he believed in
her long before anyone else did.
He encouraged us to open a shop and
see helps out by putting his name on
everything.
Gabrielle ran the business entirely
on her own and began hiring women's.
You increased production.
Boy and Coco were the perfect path because
they were both passionate about each
of that respective businesses and
had a mutual respect for one another.
All the capital used his experience to
help look over contracts and negotiate
the business deals,
but the rest was all on her.
Even before opening how fast sharp Chanel
already has loyal can tell from Paris.
It became successful right out of the
gates and she began seeing profits almost
immediately.
Boyan Coco use the money.
It's about just a lavish townhouse in
Paris which doubled as a fashion studio.
The whole of the ground floor was an
open space filled with a workshop.
She created jobs for women in the local
area and just staff was growing all the
time upstairs. She kept in a Polman's
and whenever capitol was in Paris,
he lived with her there.
Then.
Then that's what she did to prove how
success Coco Chanel could never be seen as
the marrying type in the
eyes of the aristocracy.
As a member of a noble family off the
capital was expected to end as a fan.
Erin's marry someone with a title.
In 1918 he had an English woman named
Diana Windom who was a widow and related
to and assortments of ELLs and Dukes,
but he and Chanel,
they was still very much in love and
it's continued that relationship behind
closed doors. On the 22nd of
December, 1919 off the capital,
died in a car crash on his way
to spend the holidays with Coco.
His was on Christmas Eve.
They were together for nine years and
Chanel plans you live out the rest of her
life with him.
She was just 35 years old when he died
off the capital of being the love of her
life and no other man ever came
close to replacing him. Years later,
her name would be known around the
world and those same hours to craft.
So you refuse to accept a,
we'd be fighting to where,
how designs they came up,
points in her life.
When has celebrity catapulted her to a
place where she could have married anyone.
She wants it but she never did the one
man she wants it to be a husband was gone
forever.
He knew her before,
during and after a success and
there was no way to replace that.
But she had a resilience that helps her
to keep going no matter what she said.
When you're feeling sad, add bold
lipstick and attack. Okay. Okay.
So just before we get into
the fashion and war and Nazis,
let me take a moment to tell you about
Squarespace who make videos like this.
Pulsatile Squarespace empowers dreamers
makers and do is it gives them tools to
bring their creative ideas to life.
Squarespace also makes this very easy.
They've got this all in one platform.
So you can just claim a domain,
build a website, and even if you
want to, you can sound online.
There's no fussing around with getting
a domain from, you know, one website,
buying that,
transferring it over to Squarespace and
then working out how to sell something
or whatever. It's all neat and tidy
on Squarespace all in one place.
Very nice. Plus it's not going to look
too shabby either and by not too shabby,
I mean it's going to look fantastic.
They've got award winning templates,
a perfect starting points.
Then what you do is you customize
them to your heart's content,
much like Coco Chanel and those suits
plus this 24 seven customer support,
chat and email, and they've got loads
of accessible and is not confusing.
Documentation on how to make your website
plus email marketing and I was to keep
in touch with your fans or your
customers. Squarespace. It makes it easy.
Get that domain, you get that site
belt, get a shop up and running.
If you're one too easy,
go to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch,
I go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics and save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain.
And let's get back to Coco Chanel
off to the unexpected death of her beloved
boy Coco Chanel need to define a new
business partner. At that time,
she had over 300 employees.
She was designing couture dresses that
were selling for over 3000 francs each.
In today's money that's
more like $38,000 per dress.
She had an entire army of
women making these things.
You would think that this should have
proven that she was more than capable of
running a successful business best?
Well, no, she was still a woman,
so the banks refused to
deal directly with hub.
It would become impossible for her to
run a business on cash alone and it was
completely necessary for how to
seek help from a new male partner.
The law banning women from
opening bank accounts.
It would not change until 1965 after
the passing of the French family law.
This is when she met Pierre the Timia.
He had a reputation for working together
with other luxury brands around Paris
and the offer to become
her business partner.
The only issue was that
Chanel knew nothing about
nor or business contracts off
the capital is always had
a best interest at heart,
and he gave us the freedom to run her
business as she pleased and keep the
profits for herself.
So she was too trusting and
she unwittingly signed a
contract that said Pfs II
ma was entitled to take 90%
of our business profits.
Even though this contract,
it was ridiculously unfair,
is meant that Chanel could stay in
business and she did not let this setback.
You've got the best of that.
In 1921 Chanel began working with the
celebrity puffy and chemist named Ernest
burrow. At the time, women were wearing
oils that had a single floral scent.
She wants us to create a perfume with
the layers which developed over time.
This is when they created Chanel number
five and it became one of the best
selling perfumes in the
weld for years to come.
Perfume and candle makers would copy the
idea of mixing various sense together
to create a unique experience.
Before Chanel.
Women never wore black unless they
were in mourning in the 1920s vogue
competitor, iconic little
black dress to Ford's model t.
It was simple elegance and revolutionary.
Soon enough,
people around the world what?
Looking to Chanel for inspiration.
It was a ripple effect and women's
clothing in the rest of the wells without
Coco Chanel. There's no telling what
kinds of clothes women would be wearing.
Today is data. It should now
reflect it. On that time saying,
I gave women a sense of freedom.
I gave them back their bodies
bodies that were drenched in sweat.
She had a fashions finery, lace
courses, underclothes padding,
despite the fact that she swore off,
have a marrying Chanel continued
to be in relationships with men,
but then that's how
powerful they may have been.
She always stayed true to herself. If
she dated Grand Duke, Dimitri Pavlovich,
who was related to the Russian
Remann Hall family. Next was Edward,
the eighth Prince of Wales and before
the dawn of world war two she began a
relationship with a German man named
Barron Hans Gunther von Dinklage.
Looking at a track record,
it would seem that she had a personal
goal of trying to see if she could date at
least one iris to crash from
every country in Europe,
but not decision to be in
a relationship with Vaughn.
Dinklage would become both a blessing
and to cuss. Just a few years later,
the Nancy bought,
he would rise to power and Chanel's
lover would reveal his true colors.
By the 1930s business was absolutely
booming as they needed all the space they
could guess and the house of Chanel,
how role female stuff increased in numbers
and it became necessary for Chanel to
move out of the studio
and into the Hotel Ritz,
which was directly across the
street from our business. Hey,
1936 there was a labor movement in
France and workers were demanding better
conditions across the country.
On the 26th of April or
Coco Chanel arrives at our
studio to see that all of our
employees were sitting
on the floor and protest.
They all refuse to work unless their
wages were increased and their work hours
were lessons.
Chanel was outraged because she already
paid these women higher wages and gave
more vacation time than
any of the business.
Instead of giving into their demands,
she fired every single one of them on the
spot saying that they were in grateful
and that she could do the walk on our
own, but they refuse to move. Finally,
she gave in to their demands for the
sake of getting on with the work. Now,
in 1939 Germany had occupied Poland's
and Chanel knew that it was only a matter
of time before they were coming
for France. It's possible.
That's how boyfriends vom Dinklage lesson
knew that the takeover was imminent.
She paid off all 300 of our workers
and encourage them to seek safety.
Before it was too late.
Coco Chanel,
she was not going to need that
business though the metal.
What happens just three months later,
Germany occupied France,
the Nazis destroyed the businesses and
the homes of countless numbers of French
people. The Nazis even took over.
The hotel. Ritz is the headquarters,
so Chanelle very literally how to live
among them. How Homans our business.
We're both safe. So long as she continued
that relationship with Vaughn Dinklage,
but knowing Chanel,
she would have hated this.
She never wanted to be beholden
to any men. That's a learned,
the ones who thought they
could rule the world.
The Nazis knew that she was close
friends with the British royal family,
so they asked if she would become
one with that secret agents.
In 1943 she was given the code name
model hat on a trip with Vaughn Dinklage.
She met with Winston Churchill and
handed him a letter which gave Geminis
demands for England's surrender.
Obviously he didn't take the offer and
it wouldn't be surprising if he crumpled
up the paper where he stood.
There is no way of knowing what was
said between Churchill and Chanel,
which she actually double agent divulging
Nazi secrets. We will never know,
but when the war was over,
Chanel was never brought to trial
for cooperating with the Nazis.
She didn't have a spoke about that time
and buried deep like she did with all of
the other unpleasant
memories and her life.
Coco Chanel ever said anything publicly.
There was antisemetic.
The Yoni documented issues she ever
had was with Pierre [inaudible],
who just so happens to be Jewish.
Often the Nazis occupied France.
They were seizing any property
that belonged to the Jews,
and that included businesses.
She wrote in that to,
to the Nazi government asking if there
was a chance that she could buy back the
remaining 90% of house Chanel.
However,
the family temporarily sold their business
entities to Christians during the war,
and that already fled to safety.
They're all plenty of people who cannot
forgive Coco Chanel for cooperating with
the Nazis. But for a moment,
just put yourself in her
shoes. She had two choices.
Break up with her boyfriends,
condemn the Nazis and lose everything
well bite tongue and keep on pretending
for the benefits of maintaining the life
that she had worked so hard to build.
She chose a life and if
she were alive today,
she probably wouldn't even bother to
explain how decisions in her own words.
I don't care what you think
of me and I think about you.
I've told when the war was over in 1945
Chanel dumped from Dinklage quicker than
you can say,
Oh Fida Zane.
She then moved on to having an effect
with a Spanish artist, Salvador Dali,
which is an interesting
choice to say the least.
Yeah.
When the war was over in 1945 Coco
Chanel was 62 years old and she no longer
felt inspired to create new clothes.
She chose to retire from the fashion world
for years and lived off the royalties
from the sales of her perfume.
In 1958 she found her second wind at the
age of 75 she unveiled new designs and
reopens House Chanel. This sponsor
resurgence in the brand's popularity,
Coco Chanel trays,
a man named Karl Lagerfeld's to
be his successor for the brands.
She had more than enough money to
retire and live a comfortable life,
but she worked until the day she died
on January the 10th 1971 when she died,
she was 87 years old and touch an
estimated net worth of $100 million.
Now, this might sound like a lots of
money, but do keep in mind the Pfs, him,
his grandsons still own 90% of
Chanel even to this very day.
Then Alan,
multibillion as today,
many people think of Chanel as a brands
that is intimidating and unattainable,
but for those who look at the price tag,
they missed the point Coco Chanel was
quoted saying on more than one occasion
that she believed people should wear.
What makes them happy?
What are the colors you feel great
in and the style that makes you feel
comfortable instead of trying to
be flashy or to follow a trend,
your attitude and the way
you carry yourself speaks
far more than the clothes on
your back. She said, fashion is not
something that exists in dresses.
Only fashion is in the sky,
in the street.
Fashion has to do with ideas the way
we live and what is happening. Now,
before we end today's video,
I just want to say that our audience on
biographic says I need about 10% female
and we often look at these analytics
when we decided what videos to make.
If you're a woman in the audience,
please do subscribe.
So we know you're out there.
And if you feel inspired by
the story of Coco Chanel,
please share this with someone in your
life that you know would appreciate it
too. And as always,
thank you for watching.